I know this is a crazy thing to say but
I I I know I'm gonna get roasted for
this Darius Rucker has this really great
quote
um when he was a shut up DACA when he
wrote when he wrote let her cry though
he introduces it every Hootie and the
Blowfish show he introduces Let Her Cry
he he says this story goes
um uh Bonnie Raitt one time told me that
every songwriter has one great song in
them one great one and this is my Ode to
Bonnie rape and he wrote it talks about
Let Her Cry but Bonnie writes exactly
right every songwriter is so every great
Songwriter's got one brilliant one in
them
um and I wonder I do wonder how that is
and I'm gonna ask him a similar question
uh because I have a theory I might be
crazy about it but you know that is so
amazing you bring that up because I
literally am staring at my screen trying
to figure out the title of the Bonnie
Raitt song that she just won the Grammy
for
you know well I mean this show was all
about you know new music and then here
comes a singer-songwriter who just puts
her heart
I know but but may I look I I wish that
we did a Grammy episode and I could you
know let out at all the secrets of the
Grammy voter but but can I be totally I
mean look look there are 350. Crush my
heart you're gonna a little bit a little
bit I just just to pull the curtain back
there's about 350 voters
um you know the four main categories
everybody's got to vote in and then you
have well you only have 10 votes first
and foremost there are 200 categories
but you have to oh you're you're you
have to limit it to 10 votes you have to
also only vote you have to vote in the
four main categories artist of the year
song of the year record of the Year Best
New Artist you have to vote in those
four all 350 voting members have to and
then the rest of the six you get to sort
of you know shift and shave wherever you
want it to go but they prefer you to be
in your area of expertise so when they
opened up the nomination process and the
nominees to 10 different nominees for
best new artists best you know for the
main categories
you're going to get splintered votes you
know you've got probably a hundred
people vote or 75 people voting for you
know
let's say let's put it this way if
there's 200 people voting
half of them are going to go to Beyonce
half of them are going to go to
uh uh
Harry Styles so then who's this
everybody's third favorite song probably
is gonna win in in years like this all
right no
oh wow
these things are just talking points I
get that that's not what was not my
point I I guess my point was the fact
that she was even in the room
um is
worth noting because it's a great song
It's a touching song yeah I understand
that but but at the same time she's in
the room because they throw a bone to
the music purists every year I mean
there's one of these in there every year
I mean look midnight blue back one years
ago uh how do you do what you do how do
you not how do you feel not just icky
who said I didn't
but like the idea the idea of like all
right but the idea the idea that
somebody like most of these Grammy
winners like yeah I totally get that
some of these categories are only
getting 25 votes man I know I know okay
so the winners
yeah it's like Oscars and movies they're
bought you know the studio bot I get
that I I guess my point was it it's a
great song It's a simple it is a good
song
song it's an old-fashioned John Prine
song which is what she tried to write
I'm just glad it gotten you know
attention okay now you got it now you're
sitting there throwing poo poo on it
okay
who uses the word poopoo me I'm going
old school because it's Bonnie Raitt I
could have said Kaka
man the words poo poo and Bonnie rate
the same sentences I'm using poop
because the vibrate
I don't think that she wants to be
Associated yeah no she didn't want this
yeah she didn't want that anyway but yes
it is it is a good song and yes it
deserved the attention I'm just saying
that they they throw music purists these
kinds of things every year and I'm I'm
shocked honestly that she won but I
trying to explain to you why she did no
boats are split four different ways if
we're very you know deserving songs and
she just happened to be you know did I I
never for a minute believed that the
entire voting block was a unanimous yeah
no well I just I think it surprises most
people that there's only 350. that is
for boats out there yeah that is
surprising and you will you and you can
only vote 10 times there's only 10 votes
that you can I would think most people
think it's completely based on numbers
like whoever had bazillion streaming
wins you know well I mean yeah that's
the reason why Justin Bieber has no
Grammys you know it has nothing to do
if I'm not mistaken maybe you know some
uh tertiary ones but uh yeah I get it
um and I don't you know I never get too
excited about those things they're all
talking points they're designed they're
like you know Rolling Stones top 500
they're all about getting people like
you and me to talk about it so but yes
I'm very excited that she won don't
don't get me wrong I'm very excited
about it I could tell I love I love
bunny right I love Bonnie Wright by the
way speaking of Bonnie Raitt one artist
that I'm surprised we haven't seen come
back to Bonnaroo you know I mean I think
that she was was it 2003 or four she was
there I can't really remember maybe six
but I would love to bring Bonnie right
back in one of those late afternoon
terrific